The researchers want all participants to believe that they're taking the
medication. This prevents participants from being biased concerning the
effectiveness of the drug. If they all believe that they're taking the
medication, then we're controlling for this bias. Not letting the participants
know which treatment they received is called blinding. Researchers use these
techniques when they suspect that knowing which treatment you're receiving might
influence your behavior. The inactive pill in this case is called a placebo.
Placebos are fake treatments so that the control group is unaware that they are
being treated differently. When I say they're treated differently, I mean
they're not receiving the medication The researcher's didn't tell the
participants which pill they received, because of something called the placebo
effect. People who know they're taking a placebo, might subconsciously think
that the placebo's not doing anything. And this will influence the results when
they report how well they slept. Getting back to the quiz answers. This first
option is untrue. Researchers only use deception when they suspect that knowing
the actual intent of a study may influence the participants behavior. And in
that case information is kept hidden until the end of the study. These two
options are also not true. Participants in experiments need to provide their
informed consent before the research can expose them to any treatment. Letting
participants know that they may end up in the control group is part of the
informed consent